seventy five-year-old Pablo Olivares
worked all his life in construction and
earned enough to support his family of
seven he also paid his pension fund
contributions but when it came time to
retire he was in for a shock they sold
me a beautiful tale that I would receive
two-thirds of my last salary each month
instead they stole my savings mr.
olivera's receives less than a hundred
and eighty dollars a month not enough to
survive on he says he's now forced to
live with his daughter and he's
suffering from a painful hernia so he's
unable to join others on the streets
demanding Chile's private pension plan
be scrapped Chile's highly unpopular
pension system or AFP is a leftover from
the country's military dictatorship and
it strikes a sensitive chord among
protesters of all ages without the
pensions here are undignified like one
mother couldn't come today because she's
too old so I'm here for her on the 12th
consecutive day of nationwide protests
the list of grievances against Chile's
free-market economic system is growing
and protesters are finding creative ways
to express them the system is terrible
there's no opportunities we live with
these credit cards all of us choking in
our debt enough we are drowning in debt
despite the large number of people here
this is actually an unauthorized March
the government says that these people
will not be allowed to reach the
presidential palace because they have no
one with whom to negotiate the terms
because I'm like previous marches that
have taken place over many years in this
country what we're seeing here now is
large numbers of people coming here not
under any particular organisation should
not call by a particular person but
actually anonymously all of it on the
social networks
security forces use tear gas and water
cannon to prevent protesters from
advancing towards the palace but
demonstrators nevertheless seemed upbeat
as they vowed to return every day for as
long as it takes to obtain the social
reforms they're demanding to see a human
al Jazeera Santiago